[Musique]
bonsoir vous regardez le 78 les invités
nous sommes le jeudi 15 septembre merci
de nous retrouver au programme de cette
émission trois invités trois témoignages
sur le thème des transports Philippe
Yvin est président du directoire de la
Société du Grand Paris cet établissement
public est en charge de concevoir et de
construire le réseau de transport Grand
Paris Express de demain il nous parlera
notamment de la future ligne 18 qui
passera par Saint-Quentin en Yveline et
7 jours sans voiture un défi organisé
par le Parc naturel régional de la Haute
Vallée de Chevreuse Camille Lambert a
rencontré Julie Tisseron chargé de
mission écomobilité pour en savoir plus
et enfin Joséphine colmans berger
vice-présidente du conseil départemental
en charge du tourisme nous parlera de la
vélocénie une piste qui s'inscrit dans
le cadre d'un projet global de 450 km
àan de Paris au
monts-michel et la la société pardon du
Grand Paris fait sa rentrée aujourd'hui
l'occasion pour l'établissement public
de faire un point sur les différents
chantiers des futures lignes de métro
dont la ligne 18 qui reliera l'aéroport
d'Orly à la gare de versailleschantier
en passant par c-quenttin en Yveline les
enquêtes publiques sont désormais à
terminer les travaux préparatoires et
les opérations de génie civil vont
pouvoir s'intensifier je propose
d'écouter les précisions de Philippe
ivin présid du directoire de la Société
du Grand Paris il était au micro de
Nicolas kirilovitz nous avons terminé
maintenant les enquêtes publiques qui
sont obligatoire avant de pouvoir
commencer les travaux et cet été nous
avons terminé avec la ligne 15s après
avoir réalisé au printemps l'enquête
publique de la ligne 18 qui desservira
le plateau de saclé et la ligne 17 qui
va à roissi donc après le temps des
procédures c'est le temps des travaux et
donc les premiers chantiers commencent
sur la ligne 15 Sud la première ligne
qui sera mise en service fin 2022 entre
Boulogne dans les haut de scènes et
noisichamp en S Sani et en scmarne il y
en a qui sont plus avancés au niveau des
études et la première qui avait été
étudiée c'est la ligne quin Sud donc les
travaux commencent sur cette ligne mais
tout va s'enchaîner maintenant très vite
puisque les travaux préparatoires
c'est-à-dire les déviations de réseau
d'électricité d'eau de gaz vont
commencer sur la ligne 16 entre noisilg
et Saint-Denis et puis aussi sur la
ligne 14 qui être prolongé jusqu'à horly
et les études vont se poursuivre sur les
autres lignes début 2018 l'ensemble des
lignes sera en travaux la commission
d'enquête a donné un avis favorable à la
réalisation de cette ligne 18 avec
quelques recommandations dont notamment
effectivement à la demande de la mère et
des habitants de modifier le tracé à
voisin le Bretonneux ce que nous allons
faire nous avons pris en compte bien
évidemment cette demande de la
commission d'enquête et de la population
et donc le tracé va être adapté àin
d'éviter de passer sous ce quartier du
coup ça entraîne des des retards sur
cette ligne en particulier ou alors
c'est non à ce stadeelà il y a pas de
retard puisqu'on en était vraiment aux
études préliminaire maintenant le maître
d'œuvre a été désigné et donc il va
travailler sur les études d'avant-prjet
et c'est à ce niveau des études
d'avant-prjet qu'on fixe définitivement
le tracé de la ligne et la position des
gares on a organisé plusieurs centaines
de réunions de concertation et nous
continuons puisque y compris quand les
travaux commencent nous mettons en place
des comités de suivi de chantier avec
les riverins avec les commerçants les
associations pour signaler tous les
problèmes que pourrait rencontrer le
chantier la dimension environnementale
c'est aussi très important d'abord dans
la gestion des chantiers eux-mêmes il
faut qu'ils soient respectueux de
l'environnement dans les compensations
écologique aussi puisque parfois on est
obligé d'abattre des arbres ou de
modifier le paysage et donc la loi nous
oblige et on le faisons volontiers à
compenser ces modifications de
l'environnement en plantant des arbres
ailleurs en créant des des Mar
écologique donc toutes ces compensations
écologiques nous les mettons évidemment
en place avec les élus locaux et nous
continuons à parler transport et
mobilité propre avec le parc naturel
régional de la Haute Vallée de Chevreuse
il organise pour la 2e année l'opération
7 jours sans voiture du 17 au 25
septembre une trentaine de volontaires
vont tester les modes de transport
alternatif vélo assistance électrique
covoiturage ou autostop plusieurs
solutions sont mises à leur disposition
Camille Lambert a rencontré Julie
Tisseron elle est chargée de mission
écomobilité pardon pour en savoir plus
regardez nous sommes au château de la
Madeleine pour parler écomobilité du 17
au 25 septembre l'opération 7 jours sans
voiture est lancé dans la vallée de
Chevreuse pour en parler avec nous Julie
Tisseron bonjour Julie bonjour alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer
quelle est cette opération 7 jour sans
voiture en quoi ça consiste alors cette
opération 7 jour sans voiture est
organisée donc dans le cadre de la
semaine européenne de la mobilité qui a
pour objectif de proposer à 32
volontaires habitants du territoire du
Parc Naturel de laisser leur voiture au
garage pendant 7 jours et d'utiliser des
moyens de transport alternatifs à la
voiture qui seront mis à disposition par
le parc naturel et ses partenaires alors
ces moyens de transport alternatif quels
sont-ils du vélo sur ch alors du vélo
électrique assistance électrique
essentiellement donc on aura 29
participants qui vont utiliser ce moyen
de transport
on aura également une trottinette
électrique et deux personnes qui vont se
lancer dans du covoiturage avec une
application weop qui est une application
d'autostop connecté en fait où en temps
réel on peut mettre passagers et
automobiliste en lien voilà pour
covoiturer alors pourquoi le le vélo
électrique parce que on pense forcément
vélo entre guillemets traditionnel vélo
classique pourquoi électrique pour
faciliter peut-être un peu les
déplacements alors voilà pour faciliter
les déplac placement notamment parce
qu'and on va alltre Chevreuse on est
quand même sur un territoire très
valallonné et l'important c'est de
pouvoir surpasser un peu ces obstacles
souvent qui font peur aux personnes pour
aller travailler en vélo donc le vélo
électrique est vraiment idéal pour
monter les côtes et ne pas arriver en
sueur au travail notamment c'est des
personnes qui avaient déjà l'habitude de
s'inscrire comment dire dans une
démarche un petit peu écologique qui
avaient déjà l'habitude de ce genre
d'opération l'objectif c'est aussi de
trouver des personnes justement qui ont
pas l'habitude de se déplacer autrement
qu voiture euh pour vraiment les inciter
à changer leurs habitudes en terme de
mobilité donc tout le monde est accepté
voilà on a fait une sélection assez
large justement pour que tout le monde y
participe ce n'est pas la première
édition vous l'aviez déjà fait l'an
dernier tout à fait d'accord et pourquoi
l'avoir l'avoir refait alors il y avait
un réel engouement oui il y a eu un
engouement on a été agréablement surpris
de voir parmi les personnes qui avaient
testé des vélos électriques que voilà
certaines ont continuer à aller en vélo
au travail
et de voir vraiment que il y a une
volonté des habitants de de changer de
mode de déplacement de par voilà
justement la la pollution ambiante qu'on
a régulièrement en région parisienne
donc on s'est dit il faut qu'on relance
cette édition et d'être en vélo euh on
redécouvre son paysage on prend contact
plus avec son environnement et euh voilà
on prend plaisir tout simplement aller
travailler alors qu'avant c'était plus
une corvée on était dans les
embouteillages en voiture donc il y a
aussi ça qui entre en compte ouais un
petit mot également sur cette maison du
tourisme et de l'écomobilité qui ouvrira
ses portes en 2017 est- qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez nous en dire nous la
présenter rapidement qu'est-ce qu'on y
trouver alors c'est un équipement sur
lequel on travaille depuis plusieurs
années maintenant au parc naturel avec
la mairie de Saint-Rémi et également la
RATP qui nous met à disposition ce
terrain et l'objectif c'est de
réhabiliter l'ancienne maison du
gardebarrière qui est actuellement en
place et d'en faire un équipement à la
fois touristique pour accueillir les
touristes qui viennent en Vallée de
Chevreuse apporter toutes les
informations sur le territoire et aussi
leur proposer des modes de déplacement
autre que la voiture parce que les
transports sont compliqués voilà en
Vallé de Chevreuse ils sont pas toujours
très réguliers et donc là l'idée c'est
de leur proposer de la loocation de vélo
et vélo électrique et aussi de la vente
donc il y a à la fois une dimension
touristique aussi pour les habitants
pour permettre des déplacements
pendulaires ou dans le cadre de leur
quotidien donc c'est un équipement qu'on
souhaite voir rapidement en place voilà
travaux prévus pour 2017 et ouverture en
2018 on l'espère al l'ouverture en 2018
plôt 2018 effectivement voilà et alors
un dernier petit mot sur du coup sur
cette opération 7 jour sans voiture vu
le succès de l'an dernier et de cette
année l'an prochain qu'est-ce que vous
espérez monter à plus de participants
alors c'est vrai qu'une trentaine de
participants c'est déjà bien parce que
je l'ai pas évoqué mais l'objectif aussi
c'est vraiment de les accompagner
individuellement on a une association de
conseil en mobilité qui est
l'association wmove qui les accompagne
au quotidien et pour que ce soit de
qualité on voilà on s'efforce de ne pas
trop élargir le nombre de participants
pour qu'ils se sentent vraiment bien
accompagné euh voilà après on verra
l'année prochaine si ça prend encore
comme l'an dernier on relancera la chose
avec plus de partenaires et ce qu'on
souhaiterait c'est avoir davantage
d'entreprises partenaires cette année on
en a deux on a le CEA de saclé et Crédit
Agricole de Saint-Quentin en Yveline
et on souhaite que les entreprises se L
aussi dans l'aventure et communique
auprès de leurs salariés c'est pas
évident mais voilà on veut agrandir
effectivement le cercle de nos
partenariats et pour s'incrire alors
pour l'an prochain pour ceux qui veulent
comment comment on faire alors il faudra
attendre du coup le début d'année
prochaine où on va relancer les
inscription en ligne sur internet ou
voilà on fera remplir un petit
questionnaire comme cette année et donc
en fonction des profils on on
sélectionnera les les candidat bah très
bien merci beaucoup J pour tout ces
détails merci et siyc le tourisme à
présent mardi 13 septembre à Chevreuse
était inauguré le parcours cyclable de
60 km lion Jouan Josas à émané une piste
qui s'inscrit dans le cadre du projet
global de la vélocénie 450 km partant de
Paris jusqu'au monts-michel nous avons
demandé à Joséphine colmans berger
vice-présidente du conseil départemental
en charge du tourisme ce qui allait
apporter ce tracé au département
regardez on est ravi parce que ça va
nous permettre de faire ce lien avec les
autres départements il faut savoir que
ça part de jouer en Josas et puis ça va
descendre jusque à Rambouillet alors il
faut savoir que pratiquement toutes les
zones mise en place par le département
au niveau de la vélocénie passe par
Rambouillet donc par cette zone
splendide et même à l'intérieur du parc
du château on a une vraie volonté sur le
département de développer ce tourisme là
qui est un tourisme en véritable plein
essort on se rend compte qu'aujourd'hui
pratiquement 25 % je dirais des des des
étrangers qui viennent ici et bien se
servent de ces zones de vélocennie pour
se déplacer il faut savoir aussi que
c'est pas uniquement un loisir c'est
vraiment du tourisme puisque ce qui
emprunte je dirais ces cette ces chemins
là que nous avons mis en en place et
bien font des nuités ça veut dire que
nous cherchons véritablement à faire un
développement autour de cela avec des
restaurants des hôtels des gites des
maisons d'accueil de façon à ce que ce
ça devienne vraiment un tourisme en
développement et économique c'est le
fondamental du département nous avons
une vraie volonté aujourd'hui au niveau
du département de développer tout ce qui
tout ce qui est
pépite que ce soit au niveau patrimonial
on est dans un espace ici au château de
la Madeleine qui est véritablement une
vraie pépite de notre département mais
également par le biais de ce nouveau
tourisme qui est la véloignnie et c'est
pour ça qu'on est ici aujourd'hui parce
qu'on est très fier d'avoir pu finaliser
ce projet des 60 km alors justement un
petit mot sur le bilan du tourisme dans
les ivelines comment est-ce que ça s'est
porté cette année 2015 2016 avec les
différents attentats euh quel bilan
est-ce que vous vous pourriez dresser on
est dans un bilan je dirais peut-être
pas aussi fortement impacté que sur la
région plus proche de Paris où vous
l'avez dû l'entendre il y a plus de 30 %
de chute au niveau de présence
touristique sur le département on a eu
également une baisse on a pu le
constater bien sûr par nos grands sites
comme le de Versailles où il y a eu une
baisse assez conséquente surtout en
concomitance avec la période des
attentats on a un avantage ici sur sur
sur le département c'est d'avoir des
zones rurales importantes des zones qui
permettent aussi je dirais de rassurer
les touristes puisqueaujourd'hui la
vraie difficulté c'est tout ce qui est
rassemblement surppulation et c'est pas
tout à fait comme ça qu'on voit le
tourisme des cvilines on a aussi une une
présence très forte au niveau médiatique
au niveau internet cette année rien que
cette année on avait 2 millions de
personnes qui sont venues sur le site de
de yvline tourisme qui est bien sûr
porté par le département et je pense que
ça aussi ça a contribué à ce qu'on nit
pas une baisse trop importante de notre
tourisme local alors justement ce ce ce
type de parcours ça permettra de
développer de relancer le tourisme dans
les
ivlines véritablement oui parce que
comme je vous disais tout à l'heure
aujourd'hui on se rend compte que c'est
un véritable essort c'est très important
c'est très attendu ce côté je dirais
redécouverte de la nature être vraiment
impliqué à l'intérieur avoir une
proximité avec aussi bien la faune la
flore c'est un vrai engouement on se
rend compte aussi que les tours opérator
sont très avide de cela ilinscrivent de
plus en plus à l'intérieur de leur
proposition touristiqu donc je pense
qu'on est c'est pas du tout une mode un
effet mode c'est c'est dans l'air du
temps et c'est une attente véridique et
véritable c'est à présent la fin de
cette émission merci de nous avoir avir
suivi retour du 78 et les invités lundi
très bonne soirée sur téfil
[Musique]